this is Sol again and this is part four
on this series that we're doing at
Stanford Medical School with dr.
Connelly all right Sal we're back here
again this is now the fourth of the
slides and this would be now the
business for why that segment of colon
was removed this is the colon cancer
well well so just to orient we'll go now
to come to the drawing which is like
you're saying before up here this is the
this is the lumen right here right on
out here that's the lumen is the inside
of the inside the right side out here
this is the rest of your belly right
where the bowel is all kind of rotating
around in the abdomen right and so um is
there a word for like inter abdominal
yeah peritoneal peritoneal is okay the
peritoneal cavity is where all the bowel
loops are kind of just all right it's
moseying around it's okay and then what
we have here is this is the important
part which is this is the muscle right
that allows peri stall psious yes that's
the peri I learned that inhale that's
the the kind of moving the undulating
motion to push stuff yep right it'll go
and it'll sort of milk it along and all
right just move long right so you can
see the muscle looks all fine there
that's how thick it's supposed to be and
it all looks fine over here so let's go
what what scale is this like how thick
is that much and so we're now once again
our tiny little red blood cells are
those little dots there right and so
we're talking about the thickness here
as a few millimeters that muscle is
about if you remember back to this guy
that was about six millimeters so it's
about that's about six okay okay
millimeters thicker that's actually
strong right a very very strong muscle
and you can kind of see it goes up here
it kind of comes around here but it's
looking like it's troubled home on this
area yes and this this stuff all the
stuff this is just this once was
probably a polyp and turn into a kind of
this massive polyp yeah so we have the
normal over here for the lining this is
where it's going dysplastic right
looking a little bit bad there there's
where it's going dysplastic and so now
what happens is you've got these edges
of dysplasia when people the medical
fields say plastic they're saying that
word means tissue
well plastic and generally plastic
surgery or the plastics of as far as a
material sign
it means moldable I see it also means
you can grow with it
eyes change shape right so we call
something plus it's moldable tissue it's
the shape a shape a shape and so the
shape changes were wrong I see
and actually dysplasia can refer to a
cell tissue and organ or an entire limb
okay so okay just means it grew wrong
Isador molded wrong so now this this is
where we have the cell dysplasia this is
all the bad stuff right and it basically
started probably somewhere up there and
is invading right Easter's one one cell
up there just started dividing
uncontrollably that's right it's exact
but it started from one cell being very
bad it often though starts and I'm going
to change now so we're gonna lose our
art okay so what I'm going to do is
change is that it often starts though
from one of these right meaning maybe a
cell went bad
right around there right now really is
starting it's only say growth it's not
just one cell it's all of us descended
it's descendants and billions of cells
right are growing in order millions and
billions are downward Nord right now
right in this case grow all the way
through well and so you can see the
scale yeah is it not only grew a little
bit it went right through the muscle
yeah Wow okay so going back to this guy
here this is now and there are some like
that the body does have things to fight
this off but it was unsuccessful that's
right and so there are certain
conditions where if you decrease the
immune functions right you'll get cancer
I see and so it still argued though
whether it's that you immune system is
decreased you got a virus and right the
virus caused the cancer right or whether
it's there's a lot of surveillance right
and that holes are no show that viruses
got me it's fascinating it's because
viruses are messing with are sometimes I
mean isn't the significance of our own
DNA from ancient viruses and yeah and I
think there's a couple big categories is
that viruses can get into your DNA where
I really screw up the DNA and you know
integrated into it but they also like we
said before it can lead to irritation
alright and we're so growth and have
troubles there make sense so now we're
back here in which we're looking at the
cancer which probably like you said
started here and is
growing including spreading out all the
normal tissue around it Wow
and so we're going to look now at the
cells so zoom in zoom time hang on to
your hat yeah okay so what we're going
to do is first probably go into a lower
power here is look at the edges of this
so once again we find normal right and
so this is even not perfectly normal you
can see it's a little bit dividing and a
little bit irritated right so this is
irritated along the edge hyperplasia
Jackel exam something alright so so then
what we have now is as you go in deeper
these are the areas which normal but
this is all kind of coming out you know
like we're saying up here kind of
growing out in all directions this is
now where you can see the cancer next to
normal you know we've talked before
about dysplasia this is really bad right
capital d yep small children off the
street could be able to tell you that
this is bad right and so whenever they
watch this video yep exactly okay and so
these are the normal ones they're doing
their J OB job right making them using
nuclear at the bottom what is this guy
doing right this is yeah just chaos yeah
so before we talked about carcinoma in
situ right cancer in spot if you saw
cells this bad you'd say do not let them
go far ice because they will have a
tendency invade they're crazy so this
right here is a bunch of the cells
that's a bunch of the cells there these
guys here you can see they're really
haphazard they're growing they're not
doing their so if uh if we found a polyp
that had this stuff that didn't cross
that boundary line yet we still would
say no we got to take this you know well
I guess we already took it out okay so
um so cancer the colon is one of the
ones where surgical cure is still
classic right cut it out and you're
probably in pretty good shape right and
so there you'd say well if is a tip of
the polyp and look like this I think we
got it out but you'd say to yourself we
better watch this purse I see so if the
whole polyp kind of look like that
you're like ah let's cut out a bigger
section yeah then you might so if it's
going down into the neck or getting a
little further or if you cut across it
at the margin then watch out but here's
the problem is remember how I said up
here it's not a big deal but once you
get down near the Hawley's and arteries
these guys are running amok down by the
veins of your so you actually see these
kind of these cells have split off yeah
so
and see these guys here so that's one
little nest to sell there's one that's
probably right there a cancer cell just
dying to get into that little vein right
so this is actually I can never say the
word metastasis this is it we're seeing
it this is where would come from we're
starting to happen so these guys are the
bad actors they're growing in next to
these very fragile little blood vessels
and so that guy is knocking on the door
right once it gets in here that's a
venial meaning a little vein right
that's the road out right and it just
looks like a circle here because it's a
two-dimensional cross-section of it but
it should imagine popping in or out of
our screen yeah so be pumping in our
screen so this guy would kind of go in
and out screen connect to this one and
then it would go out and it's officially
recognize a word metastasize once it's
it's found a beachhead someplace else
um that's right so it's considered a
metastasis where let's say the cell got
into the vessel right if it left the
region okay so it went to the long I see
but the slaver is looking like it this
is looking like you really are worried
that this could metastasize right and so
what's interesting about this is that
when you look at something like this
there's such a thing called for cancer
grade right and what grade is is
basically what we've been just talking
about how bad does that look right right
and so the grade is wow that looks nasty
right I think that's nasty a technical
term actually we use it quite a bit
people say what would that timber show
we said it was nasty when we talk about
nastiness it's a lack of behavior if you
can get a cell where the nucleus gets
that big or sometimes it's that big
there's chaos right and there's chaos
not just a nuclear size but how it
behaved I guess the nuclear size is what
is a telltale because that means that
the cell is devoting a lot of its
resources for replication and it's a
replication but it also means to me that
normally things in the cell are very
orderly right you do not divide your DNA
until these things are are icy and now
it's just doing it and now it's just
left and right so so yeah this would be
a high-grade tumor Wow and then stage is
the other main thing for the stage means
where is it in the body right so in this
case um if it's these nasty cells at the
very top it's actually a lower stage
than if they're nasty cells and they've
come all the way down here so it's in
situ carcinoma would still get a stage
it's a stage zero stage zero so it's
basically you're nowhere and
if you begin to just cross over like
here right and Dade then your did a
stage one and then their depths as you
go for stages and then there's always
the other thing where did it go off to
other parts of your body right and
that's the very highest stage and so
this isn't a and this is true of all
cancers when people talk about breast
cancer I've heard it in that context
left stage one stage or stage zero
through four and so it isn't just the
size so if the if the the cancerous
tissue is big but if it's in a safe
place it could still be stage 1 or stage
it is what's interesting about staging
is almost the whole world has agreed to
do the same kind of staging right and
that staging is what we're calling T and
M and T has to do with how big it is
right in the one site and how much it's
crossed any barriers right this what the
barrier question sounds like the most
important thing it does although this
one here is are they in lymph nodes all
right right and the lymph nodes are
nearby structures where you know the
lymph goes right and so that's one what
wrote out and the other one is
metastasis right and so yeah the staging
has to do with all three I see
metastases always happens through the
the circulatory system essel Zoar does
it also happen to the lymph network and
so it's something we're going through
the lymph nodes for something like this
is that one of the first steps right but
getting to the liver and the lung is
gotta get into the blood vessel ice ice
a lymphatic in your colon connects to a
local lymph node right does not connect
through lymph only to the IC so it must
have gone in I said somewhere I see so
that's the the way it looks here and
then the final thing here when looking
at this cancer is if we go over here
this is the greatest depth of invasion
you'd ask me about the body's immune
function well if you look here now you
see how it's kind of loose and there are
all these little immune cells that's
what these guys are those are witless
immune cell we see little round guys
those are lymphocytes so that's you she
is circle attacked you yeah how do you
how can you tell the difference between
the lymphocytes and the and the cancer
cells because I'm not I thought that's
go guys yes no but they're the little
round ones so this one right here is a
classic cell which is called a plasma
cell in which there's a nucleus here and
all the rest of this is making
antibodies
you're not circling that area
I'm just drawing so this guy is this
one-eyed room right okay you're zooming
in on yes giving on that so yeah that's
a plasma cell meaning it's a nuclei just
want to clarify what you've circled
there just cuz it could be a little bit
confusing we have this big circle yeah
is maybe we should this is why I should
leave it to the pros no no no just
because I'm getting confused so you're
not you're not circling that area then
oh it looks like zoomed in right there
plasma that's that's a plasma cell
that's making antibodies problem right
against the term right right and so so
that's the immune response in that spot
and how do you how do you know that's I
mean that looked very similar to the
cancer cells Tom this one's a little
hard to tell you in real much could you
turn up the light and have a very
specific look to the network and then
these guys over here have little pink
granules in them right which is a type
of immune cell and then so when looking
through here on this death which ones
are cancerous here okay so now let me
just get over here this one here and
then come out just a little bit let me
go here is that when looking at these
guys these are all inflammation the
nearest cancer cell where I could bet
the farm are these guys up here
oh okay see when you see on this view it
becomes more obvious yes they definitely
look different they look different so
then when you come out here you can see
there's the cancer this is the body's
reaction to the can see right there I
see at the missed zone and there are
therapies based on trying to get more of
this Wow immune response that's that's
that's amazing
very cool